npc's forecasts are
exceptionally large at present
the source of these risks and the driver
of most of the revisions to our
forecasts since the may report
is overwhelmingly
energy prices and the consequences of
the actions of russia
now in line with the conventions that we
use in the npc
the baseline projections in the august
report are conditioned on
wholesale energy prices
following their futures curves for the
next six months and then remaining
constant thereafter
the path of bank rate implied by
financial markets
and fiscal policy evolving in line with
announced government policies
but there are a range of plausible paths
for the economy
which have cpi inflation and medium-term
activity significantly higher or lower
than in the baseline projections
and with that in mind with the
uncertainty in mind that i referred to
in in the report we have included
several projections
for gdp unemployment and inflation
and a point i would draw out is that the
mpc is currently placing less less
weight on the implications of any single
set of conditioning assumptions and
projections
choosing to draw more heavily on
alternative scenarios as well and again
consistent with the
point i made about uncertainty
now and unlike some many recent press
conferences in view of this i thought it
would be helpful
as i go through my opening remarks to to
use some charts so you'll there we are
you'll see some charts coming up uh
we'll also be publishing these charts as
well uh hopefully their reviews most of
them but not quite all of them by the
way are in the monetary policy report
but not quite all of them
now since they may report as this chart
shows the most significant piece of news
has been the further sharp increase in
energy prices you can see it in the
orange line
as against the purple line which is the
line from may
and
from that you can see we can see that
wholesale gas futures prices for the end
of this year that's right at the hump
that you see on the orange line have
nearly doubled since may
moreover they're almost seven times
higher than implied by the futures curve
a year ago
and that's overwhelmingly a consequence
of russia's restriction of gas supplies
to europe
and the risk of further cuts
and you can see the when i talked about
the conditioning assumption and the the
way in which we hold the price constant
after six months you can see that from
the two dashed lines that appear on the
chart
the consequence of this is that
near-term inflationary pressures have
intensified significantly
cpr inflation is now expected to peak at
just over 13 percent in q4 of this year
and to remain at very elevated levels
throughout much of 2023
the bulk of that further increase
reflects higher wholesale prices feeding
through to retail energy prices with a
further large rise in the off-gem price
gap projected in october the npc will
take the necessary action
to return inflation to the two percent
target sustainably in the medium term in
line with its remits
the scale pace and timing of any further
changes in bank rate will reflect the
committee's assessment of the economic
outlook and inflationary pressures
the committee will be particularly alert
to indications of more persistent
inflationary pressures
and will if necessary act forcefully in
response
i recognize the significant impact this
will have
and how difficult the cost of living
challenge will continue to be for many
people in the united kingdom
inflation hits the the least well-off
hardest
but if we don't act to prevent inflation
becoming persistent
the consequences later will be worse
and that will require larger increases
in interest rates